do you ever wonder how we see here and
how we feel things let me introduce you
to the world of perception okay so
perception is the way our brain
interprets the signals and it receives
from our five senses and what are those
five senses our eyes our ears our nose
our taste and the feeling of touch so
when we see something what happens
actually so our eyes send signals to the
brain and then the brain interprets them
as an image when we hear something again
our ears send signals to the brain and
the Brain interprets it as sound but did
you know our perception is also
influenced by other parameters such as
our past experiences yes our emotions
and our expectations and you know what
that means that means that two people
can perceive the same thing in a very
different manner interesting isn't it so
now you know little bit about perception
if you have such more amazing facts to
share with us please comment down below
and subscribe to our Channel don't
memorize